is it possible for maybe somebody like
me or a regular person to disappear from
the grid absolutely yeah and it's not as
hard as you might think it's not
convenient again convenience and
security
you can disappear tomorrow right i can
walk you through three steps right now
that can help you disappear tomorrow but
none of them are convenient they're all
extremely secure
right the first thing you do is every
piece of digital technology you have
that's that is connected to you in any
way is now
dead
you just let the battery run out forever
forever you never touch it again
starting at this moment what you have to
do is go out and acquire a new one
realistically you will not be able to
acquire a new one in the united states
by buying it
because to do so you would tie it to
your credit card you would tie it to a
location a time a place a registered
name whatever else so you would have to
require it essentially by theft
or through the black market so you would
want something because you're going to
need the advantage of technology without
it being in your name so you go out and
you steal a phone or you steal a laptop
you do whatever you have to do to make
sure that you can get on with the
password and whatever else that might be
as as dirty or as clean as you want that
to be we're all morally flexible here
but now you have a technological device
that you can work with
and then from there on you're just doing
whatever you have to do whether you're
stealing every step of the way or
whether you uh
you run a massive con
keep in mind that we often talk about
con men and cons do you know what the
root the word that khan is a root word
for
confidence
that's what a con man is a con man is a
confidence man just somebody who is so
brazenly confident that the people
around them living in their own
perception not perspective and their
perception they're like well this guy
really knows what he's talking about so
i'm going to do what he says so you can
run a massive con and that can take care
of your finances that can take care of
your lodging whatever amount whatever
else it is
you are whoever you present yourself to
be
so if you want to go be
if you want to be bill for the afternoon
just go tell people your name is bill
they're not going to question you
so the
intelligence the natural
web of intelligence gathering
systems we have in the united states and
in the world
are they going to
believe for long that your bill
are they until you do something that
makes them think otherwise if you are
consistent we talked about consistency
being the superpower if you are
consistent they will think you're bill
forever
how how difficult is that is that to do
it's it's not convenient it's quite
difficult is that like required training
it does require training
because why do criminals always get
caught because they stopped being
consistent
criminals i i've i've
as
i i never hesitate to admit this but
people tell me i should hesitate to
admit it so now i hesitate
because of the guidance i've gotten to
hesitate right i like criminals i'm
friends with a number of criminals
because the only people who get me like
right away who get me are criminals
because we know what it's like
to basically abandon all the rules
do our own thing our own way and watch
the world just keep turning yeah most
people are so stuck in the
in the
trap of normal thought and behavior that
when i tell them they just don't just go
tell people your name is bill
most people are going to say
that's not going to work but a criminal
be like oh yeah i did that once yeah i
just told everybody my name was nancy
yeah dude and they still believed me
yeah
criminals just get it right so
what happens with criminals is they go
to the school of hard knocks they go to
they learn criminal behavior on the job
spies go to school
we go to the best spy school in the
world we go to langley's
the farm right what's known as field
tradecraft course ftc in a covert
location for a covert period of time and
covert covert covert so if anybody from
ci is watching i'm not breaking any
rules it's all on wikipedia but it's not
coming from me yeah
but we do that's how we do it they train
us
from 100 years of experience and the
best ways to carry out covert operations
which are all just criminal activities
overseas
we learn how to do it the right way so
that we don't get caught we learn how to
be consistent more importantly we learn
how to create an operation that has a
limited life span
because the longer it lives the more at
risk you are so you want operations to
be short concise
on the x off the x
limit your room for mistakes criminals
want law they default to wanting these
long-term
operations because they don't want to
have to recreate a new way to make money
every 15 days
you